♪ MY FAMILY'S ALL ASLEE
SO I WON'T MAKE A PEEP
I'LL COOK ALL NIGH
MY MOST DELICIOUS RECIPE ♪
♪ I STILL HAV
QUITE A SURPRISE
IN THE MORNING
WHEN THEY RISE ♪
♪ THEY'LL TAKE A BIG BITE
OF MY OVERNIGHT SALA
IT'S NOT EASY TO MAKE ♪
♪ LOTS OF INGREDIENTS
IT TAKES
BUT IT'S WORTH IT TO SERVE
MY OVERNIGHT SALAD ♪
♪ TAKE A LITTLE BIT
OF LETTUCE
SPRINKLE IN SOME CHEES
A LITTLE SCOSCHE OF LEMON ♪
♪ AND A GALLON OF MAY
SO MANY RAISINS AN INSAN
AMOUNT OF PEPPER ♪
♪ NOW YOU'RE MAKING A SALAD
54 HOT DOG
LOOK WHO'S BACK IT'S MAY
DON'T SKIMP ON THE FRITOS ♪
♪ AND ROOT BEER
THE CROUTONS AND COOKIES
ADD THE PIZZA TO
OF COURSE ♪
♪ THEN I LET IT SIT
ALL NIGHT ON THE
RADIATOR ♪
♪ IN THE MORNIN
WHEN THEY RISE
MY DAUGHTER'S EYES
FILLED WITH PRIDE ♪
♪ WHEN THEY TAKE A BIG BITE
OF MY OVERNIGHT SALAD ♪
♪ THE ULTIMATE PRIZ
MY HUSBAND
KING OF THE GUYS ♪
♪ WHICH HE CHOMPS INT
FOR MY OVERNIGHT SALAD
IT'S ALL OVER THEIR FACE
MY FAMILY LOVES THE --
>> OH, MY GOD, THIS TASTES LIKE
[ BLEEP ].
WHAT THE HELL IS WRONG WITH YOU?
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO MAKE
A SALAD.
>> IT'S MY OVERNIGHT SALAD
>> MAYONNAISE AND LETTUCE LEFT
OUT ALL NIGHT?
WHAT THE HELL WERE YOU THINKING?
>> THINKING YOU WOULD BE KING OF
THE GUYS
>> NO, NO, YOU NEED HELP,
NADINE
>> MOMMY, BAXTER'S NOT MOVING.
>> I GAVE HIM A BITE OF MY
OVERNIGHT SALAD.
>> ARE YOU HAPPY, NADINE
YOU KILLED THE [ BLEEP ] DOG
ARE YOU STUPID
YOUR BRAIN IS SICK
>> MAYBE, DOES IT NEEDS A BIG
SCOOP OF MAYO?
>> THERE'S A QUARTER IN MY
SALAD.
♪ WELL THE QUARTE
IS THE THING ♪
>> NO, NADINE, NO.
JUST STOP.
COME ON, GIRLS, LET'S GO
COME ON.
>> I GUESS I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
EAT THIS ALL MYSELF.
♪
♪ OVERNIGHT SALAD
[ BELL TOLLS ]